SPEAKING ABOUT EXACTLY THAT.
SHE'LL TELL ME WHAT SHE'S
LEARNED.
>>> BUT FIRST HERE'S "MY TAKE."
AS WE WATCH INFLATION SPIKE
UPWARDS AT A PACE NOT SEEN SINCE
THE EARLY 1980s, EXPERTS ARE
DEBATING WHETHER THIS IS
WORRYING AND LONG TERM OR BENIGN
AND TRANS FORY.
I'M NOT A ECONOMIST BUT AS A
STUDENT OF HISTORY, I WONDER IF
THE RETURN OF INFLATION IS PART
OF A LARGER SHIFT THAT IS TAKING
PLACE ACROSS THE WORLD.
TO PUT IT SIMPLY, FOR DECADES IN
COUNTRY AFTER COUNTRY, ECONOMICS
TRUMPED POLITICS BUT NOW FROM
CHINA TO TURKEY TO THE UNITED
STATES, POLITICS IS TRUMPING
ECONOMICS.
TZ CON KWES OF INFLATION IS ONE
OF THE MOST FAR REACHING CHANGES
OF OUR TIME.
COUNTRIES USED TO THINK THEY HAD
TO LIVE WITH AND MANAGE
ESCALATION AND RISING PRICES.
WHEN THEY GOT OUT OF HAND, THEY
OFTEN HAD SEVERE CONSEQUENCES.
UNLIKE UNEMPLOYMENT, WHO AFFECT
JUST THE SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE JOBS,
INFLATION AFFECTS EVERYONE.
AND UNLIKE UNEMPLOYMENT, WHICH
SHRINKS WHAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
EARNED IN THE FUTURE IF YOU HAD
A JOB, INFLATION SHRINKS WHAT
YOU HAVE NOW BY ERODING THE
VALUE OF ALL OF YOUR SAVINGS.
THAT'S WHY HIGH INFLATION HAS
BEEN SO OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
POLITICAL TURMOIL FROM GERMANY
IN THE 1920s TO IRAN IN THE
1970s TO LATIN AMERICA IN THE
1980s.
WE FORGET NOW AS RECENTLY AS THE
1980s, INFLATION WAS RAMPANT
ACROSS MUCH OF THE WORLD.
COUNTRIES LIKE BRAZIL, ARGENTINA
AND PERU HAD INFLATION RATES
THAT WERE MEASURED IN THE
THOUSANDS OF PERCENT.
THE UNITED STATES KICKED OFF THE
DECADE WITH OVER 12% INFLATION.
AND IN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES LIKE
ITALY, IT ROSE ABOVE 20% AND
MOST OF THESE COUNTRIES, THE
CAUSE WAS SOME COMBINATION OF
LARGE GOVERNMENT DEFICITS, LAX
CENTRAL BANK POLICIES AND
EXTERNAL SHOTS LIKE THE OIL
CRISIS OF THE 1970s.
THESE CRISES PRODUCED A POLICY
REVOLUTION.
CENTRAL BANKS BECAME MORE
INDEPENDENT AND FOCUSED ON
TAMING INFLATION.
GOVERNMENTS IN THE DEVELOPING
WORLD BECAME MORE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE, AND IN SOME CASES
CHILE AND MEXICO, THEY BRIEFLY
TIED THEIR CURRENCIES TO THE
DOLLAR.
ONE CRUCIAL REASON THAT
COUNTRIES LIKE ITALY WERE
WILLING TO GIVE UP THEIR
CURRENCY IN FAVOR OF A COMMON
EUROPEAN ONE WAS THAT THEY
BELIEVED THAT ESSENTIALLY
MERGING THEIR MONETARY POLICY
WITH GERMANY'S WOULD ENABLE THEM
TO FIX THEIR INFLATION PROBLEM.
IN LARGE MEASURE, IT WORKED AND
BY THE EARLY 2000s, COUNTRY WERE
CONGRATULATING THEMSELVES FOR
HAVING WON THE WAR.
IT ALL SEEMS PART OF A PARADIGM
WHERE GOVERNMENTS RECOGNIZE THE
POWER OF FREE MARKETS AND FREE
TRADE.
THOMAS FRIEDMAN USED THE
METAPHOR OF THE GOLDEN STRAIGHT
JACKET TO EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENED.
GOVERNMENTS PLACED THEMSELVES IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEIR POLICY
OPTIONS WERE TIGHTLY CONSTRAINED
BY MARKETS AND AS A RESULT THEIR
POLITICS SHRANK BUT THEIR
ECONOMIES GREW.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS, IT HAS
SEEMED AS THOUGH THE OPPOSITE IS
HAPPENING ALMOST EVERYWHERE.
LOOK AT TURKEY, WHICH BY THE
2000s HAD BECOME A MODEL
DEVELOPING COUNTRY, TAMING
INFLATION AND SPURRING GROWTH.
ITS POLICYMAKERS WERE LAUDED
ACROSS THE WORLD.
TODAY TURKEY'S PRESIDENT HAS
ABANDONED EVEN THE PRETENSE OF
RATIONAL ECONOMIC POLICY, USING
THAT POLICY TO REWARD FRIENDS
AND PUNISH FOES AND ADVOCATING
MONETARY POLICY THAT IS THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT MOST EXPERTS
BELIEVE WOULD WORK.
CHILE, WHICH WAS CONSIDERED THE
MOST FISCALLY PRUDENT COUNTRY IN
LATIN AMERICA, NOW APPEARS TO
HAVE TAKEN A PATH TOWARDS A MORE
FAMILIAR LEFT WING POPULISM.
OR CONSIDER THE POSTER CHILD OF
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES, CHINA,
WHERE ECONOMIC GROWTH WAS THE
NORTH STAR OF POLICY MAKING.
TODAY XI JINPING PURSUES
POLICIES THAT OFTEN ATTACK THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN KEY GROWTH
AREAS LIKE TECHNOLOGY.
AS THE SCHOLAR ELIZABETH ECONOMY
HAS POINTED OUT, IT IS CHINA,
NOT AMERICA, THAT BEGAN THE MOVE
TO DECOUPLE THE TWO COUNTRIES
ECONOMIES AND EMBRACE
PROTECTIONISM AND ECONOMIC
NATIONALISM WHEN XI ANNOUNCED
HIS MADE-IN-CHINA STRATEGY AND
FOR ITS PART MIRRORED ITS
PROTECTIONISM WITH ITS OWN
SUBSIDIES.
THE WESTERN WORLD HAS FOLLOWED
SUIT.
DRIVEN BY AN UNDERSTANDABLE
CONCERN OF MIDDLE CLASS WAGES
AND INEQUALITY, ECONOMIC POLICY
IS NO LONGER ORIENTED TOWARDS
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
TARIFF, RELIEF AND SUBSTANCE
PACKAGES ALL REFLECT THAT
POLITICS HAS TRUMPED ECONOMICS.
CENTRAL BANKS EVERYWHERE HAVE
RUSHED IN OVER THE LAST DECADE
TO TAKE EXTREME MEASURES TO THE
RESPONSE TO THE BIG SHOCKS OF
THE AGE, THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
AND PANDEMIC.
IN THE MID-19 90s, NOT ONE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD HAD A
DEBT-TO-GDP RATIO OF 300%.
TODAY, 25 COUNTRIES HAVE
EXCEEDED THIS MARK.
THE OLD OBSESSION WITH ECONOMICS
OVER POLITICS WAS OVERDONE.
IT ACHIEVED GREAT SUCCESSES BUT
IT CREATED OTHER PROBLEMS, SUCH
AS WAGE STAGNATION.
BUT THE CURRENT EMPHASIS OF
POLITICS OVER ECONOMICS SEEMS
MORE DANGEROUS.
IT ALLOWS POLITICIANS TO ENGAGE
IN PA TRONAGE POLICIES,
PROTECTIONISM AND SHORT-TERM
GIMMICKS TO PREVENT ORDINARY
PEOPLE FROM FEELING THE PAIN OF
A CRISIS.
IN THE LONG RUN, HOWEVER, ONE
WONDERS IF IT IS THE SAME